[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing some
exciting news pertaining to a couple of
long awaited updates on the Harry Potter
TV show we had an update in the third
week of January and another update just
a few days ago so let's hope they keep
the updates coming for those unaware
back in April water bro's discovery made
the announcement that a Harry Potter TV
series is in the works each season will
be authentic to the original books and
to bring Harry Potter and these
incredible Adventures to new audiences
around the world while the Original
Classic and beloved films will remain at
the core of the franchise and available
to watch globally we are delighted to
give audiences the opportunity to
discover Hogwarts in a whole new way
says HBO CEO Casey blo in a statement
how Harry Potter is a cultural
phenomenon and it is clear there is such
an enduring love and thirst for The
Wizarding World and via the first update
released January 21st it would appear
that the upcoming Harry Potter TV series
is one step closer to becoming a reality
as a group of selected writers have
finally started pitching their ideas for
the show according to deadline a handful
of writers were commissioned to create
pictures based on the Beloved books and
those pictures were presented for the
first time in Los Angeles a few weeks
ago although the exact number of writers
involved and the full list of names
remains undisclosed some of the writers
initially connected to the project
include Michael Lesley writer of The
Hunger Games The Ballad of song birds
and snakes Kathleen Jordan creator of
teenage bounty hunters Martha hilia from
the last Kingdom and Tom Moran from the
devil's hour the top choices were said
to have then been given the opportunity
to pitch again in the UK but since that
initial announcement we've learned that
the Harry Potter television series has
become even closer to selecting its new
creative leader with the short list
being narrowed down to just three names
of which we happen to know one this news
broke at the beginning of the month the
first named finalist is Franchesca
Gardner a talented writer known for her
work on the hit show succession it's
unclear which of the previously
mentioned writers are still involved but
we do know that Franchesca alongside two
other writers is currently in contention
to guide Harry and his friends on their
small screen Journey but who is
Franchesca Gardner Harry Potter is so
important to me and taking on the role
of recreating it is no small task so it
would be criminal for me not to do a
little bit of research and see if the
story is incapable hands here's what
I've been able to find Franchesca is a
British screenwriter who has recently
found the spotlight through her success
in a variety of popular new shows
according to the Elevate podcast as a
screenwriting graduate she was was named
the UK's hottest new director from the
national film and television School most
notably Gardner was a Consulting
producer on seasons 3 and four of HBO's
highly successful show succession and
before working on the Jesse Armstrong
creation she was an executive producer
of HBO and BBC fantasy co-production his
dark materials and was a co-executive
producer of AMC's killing Eve she has
also written on shows including Stars
the rook and Amazon the man in the High
Castle and despite her relatively recent
entry into the world of mainstream film
and television Gardner has already
established herself as a talented writer
her exceptional work on the critically
acclaimed show succession and killing
Eve earning her two Emmy wins and one
Emmy nomination it would seem that her
impressive credentials speak to her
ability to bring compelling storytelling
to the screen but is she a fan of Harry
Potter and is she suited to it I think
it takes certain criteria to pull off a
successful reintroduction of Harry
Potter so here are some of my possible
hot takes first of all I think that
being British provides a unique
perspective and understanding of the
cultural nuances and settings portrayed
in the Harry Potter Universe next I
think that you have to actually be a
Harry Potter fan only a fan would have a
deep enough appreciation and knowledge
of the characters story lines and themes
to accurately capture the essence and
magic of the story listening to
Franchesca on the Elevate podcast she
encouragingly made a Harry Potter
reference within the first 5 minutes and
this was a year ago I always had the
really unappealing desire to be top of
the class and I feel very strongly
aligned with the H archetype which has
its benefits and also has its huge
downfalls and I would allocate bonus
points to those who grew up with the
Harry Potter books and films and are a
similar age to the original Harry Potter
cast as I feel that this further
solidifies your familiarity and
emotional connection with the books and
films enabling you to authentically
depict the world and its characters
having a closer connection to the Harry
Potter books as a writer or contributor
to a prospective TV series can help
prevent any injustices towards the
original work it ensures that the
essence and integrity of the books are
retained avoiding any drastic deviations
or completely different directions that
might undermine the Integrity of the
Beloved franchise if Franchesca is
indeed a front runner then I think that
we might actually be in luck here she's
British she's about the right age for
someone who would have grown up with the
Harry Potter books films and she's a
demonstrated Harry Potter fan as per her
mentioning of herione in casual
conversation as I mentioned earlier
there are still two other writers in
consideration for the series but reports
do seem to suggest that there may also
be an opportunity for more than one of
these writers to be involved a decision
on the matter is expected to be made
soon so for now we'll just have to wait
and see with the updates on potential
writers out of the way I thought I'd
also take this opportunity to do a bit
of housekeeping and address some other
pieces of info related to the series
here's what we know producers the Harry
Potter series will be produced by Bron
film and TV the production company
chaired by Rowling's agent Neil Blair
and Warner Bros television JK rling is
expected to serve as the show's
executive producer alongside bronte's
CEO Ruth Ken lets we also know that
Harry Potter producer David hayon will
be involved in some capacity though to
what extent is still unclear Heyman is
best known as the primary producer of
all eight installments of the Harry
Potter film series and I think it'd be a
shame for him not to be involved release
date the TV series announced early 2023
is expected to Premiere in 2025 26
coinciding with Warner bro's discoveries
rebranding of its streaming services as
Max with the company's Endeavor to
revamp its offerings it's evident that
they are keen on enchanting viewers with
Harry Potter's magic in recent years
there has been a demonstrated demand for
more Harry Potter content it started
with the recent and overwhelming success
of the cursed child play and was only
continued by the success of the newly
released Harry Potter game Hogwarts
Legacy which went on to sell over 22
million units as the best-selling game
of
2023 Discovery CEO David zaslav
emphasized the untapped potential of the
Harry Potter franchise at a recent
Goldman Sachs conference acknowledging
its significant impact on the company's
performance over the past two decades
alongside properties like Lord of the
Rings and DC one thing is for sure once
we do have the show on the way we will
almost unquestionably be given season
after season as time is of the essence
when dealing with aging kids we wouldn't
want a 17-year-old in third year that's
all I've got for you for now but I'll be
sure to keep you all updated as I hear
more are you excited for the show let me
know down in the comment section below
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to
live